E
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION IN
CALIFORNIA, GAVIN NEWSOM, THEY
WANT YOU TO PUT YOUR MASK BACK
ON.
APPARENTLY INDEFINITELY.
BUT FIRST TONIGHT FROM AMERICAN
CITIES ARE IN CRISIS.
LOOK AT THE STATISTICS.
THEY ARE EVERYWHERE, RATE,
ROBBERY, ASSAULT, MURDER
SKYROCKETING AND IMPORTANT THE
MURDER RATE 100%, MINNEAPOLIS
UP BY A WHOPPING 56%.
PHILADELPHIA, WASHINGTON, D.C.,
LOS ANGELES, NEW YORK, CHICAGO,
ALSO NOW SUFFERING THROUGH MAJOR
SPIKES AND VIOLENT CRIME.
NO, WHAT DO ALL THE CITIES HAVE
IN COMMON?
ONE, THEY HAVE ALL BEEN RUN AND
HAVE BEEN FOR MANY YEARS BY FAR
LEFT DEMOCRATS.
NUMBER TWO, THE SAME DEMOCRATS
THAT VILIFIED
LAW ENFORCEMENT,/POLICE BUDGETS,
DEFUNDING THE POLICE AND FAILING
TO DEFUND DISMANTLE AS
WELL AND ACTING SOFT ON CRIME
POLICIES LIKE NO BAIL
REFORM, REFUSING TO PROSECUTE
PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE VIDEO OF
RIOTING AND LOOTING INVOLVED IN
ARSON.
AND OTHER VIOLENT CRIMINALS
DURING THE SUMMER OF 2020, THEY
BENT A NEED TO ANGRY MOB AND
DIVIDE THE REALITY PLAYING OUT
BEFORE THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
MINNEAPOLIS, CITY LEADERS
ALLOWED POLICE PRECINCT TO BE
BURNED TO THE GROUND.
SEATTLE, ENTIRE CITY BLOCKS WERE
CEDED TO RIOTERS AND CRIMINALS
FOR WEEKS.
DOWNTOWN PORTLAND WAS LIT ON
FIRE ALMOST EVERY NIGHT FOR
MONTHS.
AND ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY, THE
POLICE WERE ASSAULTED.
A BRICKS AND FROZEN WATER
BOTTLES AND ROCKS AND MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS.
SEVERAL OTHER CITIES EXPERIENCED
ARSON, LOOTING ON A MASSIVE
SCALE, LOOKING AT YOUR SCREEN,
SANTA MONICA, CALIFORNIA.
WIDESPREAD LOOTING AND BROAD
DAYLIGHT.
IN CHICAGO, NEW YORK,
LOS ANGELES DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
STOREFRONTS SMASHED AND LOOTED.
TIMES SQUARE OVER THE WEEKEND, A
MARINE WAS HIT WITH A STRAY
BULLET.
IN OAKLAND OR THE CITY COUNCIL,
WHERE THEY VOTED TO DEFUND THE
POLICE.
A GUNMAN TRIED TO ROB A CAMERA
CREW DURING AN INTERVIEW WITH
THE CITY'S CRIME PREVENTION
CHIEF.
AT CITY HALL HERE IN PRETTY
BRAZEN.
A FEW WEEKS EARLIER IN
SAN FRANCISCO, IN OTHER CREW WAS
ROBBED AT GUNPOINT IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT, TAKE A LOOK.
>> AT THE CAR CAME UP HERE WHILE
WE WERE ABOUT TO DO AN INTERVIEW
IN THREE GUYS JUMPED OUT, ONE
HAD A GUN AND PUT IT TO MY FACE
AND SAID WE ARE TAKING THE
CAMERA AND DO MY CAMERA.
>> THE WHOLE ENCOUNTER WITH A
BLOCK IN HIS FACE TOOK LESS THAN
A MINUTE.
>> MY WHOLE THOUGHT AT THE
MOMENT, LET'S BECOME AND NOT GET
THIS GUY EXCITED APPEARED HE'S
GOT THE GUN.
I DON'T.
YOU TAKE THE CAMERA.
IT IS YOURS, BUT HE.
>> Sean: THE VIOLENCE IS OUT
OF CONTROL AND HAPPENING IN MANY
CITIES ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
INSTEAD OF CRACKING DOWN ON
CRIME AND RESTORING LAW AND
ORDER SO THAT WE CAN BE SAFE
SECURE AND PURSUE HAPPINESS.
THE POLICE BUDGETS ARE BEING
SLASHED.
OFFICERS ARE BEING RESTRICTED.
THEY ARE TOLD TO STAND BACK AND
STAND DOWN.
MANY CRIMINALS WHO LOOT, RIOT,
AND STEEL ARE NOT GETTING
ARRESTED.
MOST OF THOSE LOCKED UP THAT
QUICKLY LET OUT OF JAIL.
AND ALL CHARGES EVEN WITH
VIDEOTAPED EVIDENCE IS DROPPED.
FOR EXAMPLE, 118 INDIVIDUALS
ARRESTED IN NEW YORK CITY DURING
LAST YEAR'S LOOTING SPREE COME
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE CASE WAS
JUST
DISMISSED.
TONS OF EVIDENCE.
NOW AFTER A YEAR OF CHAOS AND
VIOLENCE AND MAYHEM, NO ONE IN
AMERICA SUPPORTS THIS
INSANE DEFUND THE POLICE
MOVEMENT AND ONLY 18% ACCORDING
TO A RECENT POLL.
MEANWHILE A BRAND-NEW HARVARD
HARRIS POLL SHOWS AN
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY, NEARLY
70% OF AMERICANS HAVE, IN FACT,
A FAVORABLE VIEW OF POLICE.
ACCORDING TO A PEW POLL,
MINORITIES INCLUDING
AFRICAN-AMERICANS ARE WORRIED
ABOUT CRIME AND CUTS TO POLICE
FUNDING.
OBVIOUSLY, THESE ARE NOT GOOD
NUMBERS FOR THE DEMOCRATS THAT
HAVE SAT IDLY BY AND SILENT AND
SPENT THE LAST YEAR THEMSELVES
VILIFYING THE POLICE, DEFUNDING
AND DISMANTLING.
ABOUT TONIGHT, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAVE A NEW PLAN,
THEY TELL US.
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT PLAN HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH MAKING YOUR
CITY SAFER.
INSTEAD, THE GENIUSES AND THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION ARE ACCUSING
REPUBLICANS.
THEY ARE SAYING "THEY ARE THE
ONES THAT WANT TO DEFUND THE
POLICE."
OKAY, NOT MAKING THIS UP AND WE
HAVE THE VIDEOTAPE TO PROVE IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LOOK, REPUBLICANS ARE VERY
GOOD OF STAYING ON TALKING
POINTS WHO SAY DEFUND THE
POLICE, BUT THE TRUTH IS THEY
DEFUNDED THE POLICE.
WE FUNDED CRIME, INTERVENTION
AND A WHOLE BUNCH OF OTHER
THINGS.
>> PART OF THIS ANNOUNCEMENT IS
ALSO ENSURING THE SPECIFIC
GUIDANCE TO COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY TO ENSURE THEY HAVE
FUNDING TO GET MORE COMMUNITY
POLICE AROUND THE COUNTRY.
SOMETHING SUPPORTED BY THE
AMERICAN JOBS PLAN THAT WAS
VOTED BY DEMOCRATS JUST A COUPLE
OF MONTHS AGO.
I MIGHT SAY THE OTHER PARTY WAS
FOR DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
I WILL LET OTHERS SAY THAT.
>> Sean: THAT IS WHAT YOU CALL
AN OUTRIGHT LIE.
YOU CAN EVEN CALL IT A
CONSPIRACY THEORY IF THEY
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT CRAP.
AND WHERE ARE THE SO-CALLED
FACT-CHECKERS FAKE NEWS CNN OR
POLITIFACT.
MAYBE THEY WANT TO WEIGH IN ON
THIS ONE?
THIS MIGHT BE THE MOST BLATANT
SITE IN MODERN AMERICAN
POLITICS.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE MY
WORD FOR IT BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY
HAVE PROOF.
IT IS CALLED VIDEOTAPE.
THANK GOD FOR VIDEOTAPE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YES, I SUPPORT THE DEFUND THE
MOVEMENT BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT
THE INVESTMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES, WHICH HAVE BEEN
EXTORT GLEE DEVASTING END.
>> HISTORICALLY DEFECTED END.
>> AND WE TRULY ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE REDUCTION OF OUR MIT
BUDGET AND DEFUNDING $60 BILLION
NYPD BUDGET.
>> NOT ONLY DO WE NEED TO DEFUND
BUT WE NEED TO DISMANTLE AND
START NEW ALLOWS US TO REIMAGINE
WHAT PUBLIC SAFETY SHOULD LOOK
LIKE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
>> YOU KNOW MANY CITIES IN
AMERICA ONE-THIRD OF THE CITY
BUDGET GOES TO THE POLICE.
SO WE HAVE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION.
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
>> Sean: REMEMBER LAST YEAR OF
THE DEMOCRATS, THEY WOULDN'T
CALL RIOTS RIOTS?
THE SAME DEMOCRATS NEVER
MENTIONED IT AT THE DNC.
ALL THAT HAD GONE ON LAST
SUMMER.
KAMALA HARRIS HERSELF EVEN
PROMOTED THAT BAIL FUND TO GET
VIOLENT CRIMINALS OUT OF JAIL.
DURING THE DNC, NO MENTION OF
LAST SUMMER'S VIOLENT RIOTS,
EVEN JOE BIDEN HIMSELF SAID THE
POLICE HAVE BECOME THE ENEMY.
HE AGREED THE CITIES SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY REDIRECT FUNDS AWAY
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY ARE NOW BLAMING REPUBLICANS
FOR THIS, BUT WE HAVE MORE
VIDEOTAPE TO PROVE THEY ARE
WRONG AND OUTRIGHT LYING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SURPLUS MILITARY IMPROVEMENT
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY DON'T NEED THAT.
THE LAST THING YOU NEED IS A
HUMVEE COMING IN WITH LIKE THE
MILITARY IMPEDING.
THEY DON'T KNOW ANYBODY AND
BECOME THE ENEMY.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
PROTECTING THESE PEOPLE.
MY GENERIC POINT IS THAT...
PICO CAN WE AGREE TO REDIRECT
SOME OF THE FUNDING?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: AT LEAST HE DIDN'T
SAY "COME ON, MAN COME ARE YOU A
JUNKIE?
"THIS NEW DEAL DEMOCRATIC PARTY
DEMANDED THAT THE POLICE BE
DEFUNDED.
THEY DID IT.
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS IN THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE, JOE BIDEN,
KAMALA HARRIS, THEY ALL AGREE
YOUR LOCAL DEMOCRATS ON THE CITY
STATE LEVEL THEN BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OUT OF POLICE BUDGETS.
NEW YORK, LOS ANGELES, AND
MINNEAPOLIS, THAT IS JUST A
START.
THEY REDUCED THE SIZE OF THE
POLICE FORCE.
THEY LET VIOLENT CRIMINALS OUT
OF JAIL.
THEY STOPPED PROSECUTING A
MULTITUDE OF VERY SERIOUS
CRIMES, INCLUDING VIOLENT
CRIMES, AND PREDICTABLY VIOLENT
CRIME IS SKY ROCKETING.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO BLAME
REPUBLICANS?
OKAY, MY MEMORY MIGHT BE SHORT
BUT NOT THAT SHORT.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THANKS LEE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE MUST BE
GULLIBLE AND STUPID.
AT THE SAME TIME, THIS IS THE
GUY THAT THEY PUT IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
TAKE A LOOK THANK GOODNESS FOR
VIDEOTAPE.
>> PLEASE, PLEASE SIT DOWN.
I ONCE SAID THAT TO A BIG CROWD
OF THE EVENING.
I SAID, "PLEASE SIT DOWN."
AND THERE WERE NO SEEDS.
THEY WERE ON THE FOOTBALL FIELD.
THE PRESS POINTED OUT BIDEN IS
LOSING IT.
I CAN SEE YOU ALL HAVE SEATS.
DESPITE PARTISAN IT WAS A GREAT
DEAL FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NOT JUST FOR FOLKS IN CITIES,
RED STATES, BLUE STATES, BUT FOR
EVERYBODY.
THIS JOB, THIS JOB, THE JOBS ARE
GOING TO BE CRAZY OR.
LARGELY WE KNOW THE BLUE-COLLAR
WORKERS.
>> Sean: THIS JOB, THIS JOB,
THE JOB OKAY, WE HAVE SHOWN YOU
TAPE FROM JOE BIDEN IN 2012,
2016, DOES THAT SEEM LIKE THE
SAME GUY TO YOU?
DO YOU TRUST JOE BIDEN WITH
SAFETY AND SECURITY?
DO YOU THINK YOU WILL COME UP
WITH A PLAN TO REDUCE VIOLENT
CRIME IN AMERICA?
I DON'T THINK SO.
WE WILL LET YOU DECIDE, HE
BARELY KNOWS WHAT DAY OF THE
WEEK IT IS.
HIS RADICAL NEW GREENDALE
SOCIALIST BASED, THEY SEEM TO BE
IN CHARGE AN